john what's a normal vacation like for
you
uh so i'm kind of new to the vacation
scene it's something i've been exploring
um as of late
uh
it's
hopefully being with people that i care
about hopefully doing things that i
enjoy and maybe a little learning along
the way oh there they are ladies and
gentlemen the bride and groom to be
emily and marcus
what the hell is that you son of a [ __ ]
you said we were best friends what are
you two doing here
[Laughter]
i mean do you throttle back or do you
rev it up on vacation uh depends it
honestly depends i think that it depends
on the situation if uh if i'm thoroughly
exhausted i'm not like all right let's
throttle through that's like let's give
myself a rest but if i'm if i'm game for
action it's you know all systems go dude
this is the summer of cena you have been
everywhere you're doing a million and
one things but the one theme that seems
to go through this summer is the strip
down john cena whether it is on the red
car what is this do you enjoy just
kind of stripping down
well i'm uh i've really worked hard on
this i'm comfortable with who i am and
i'm certainly not uh doing what i do for
for cool points or for
anyone's acceptance i'm trying to
entertain audiences but at the same time
i have a level of self-appreciation that
allows me to take some big swings and
not be embarrassed or or be embarrassed
but just not live in shame uh so so that
makes those moments okay i guess you
know so there's no psyching yourself up
for those moments when you're like i'm
gonna put on these tights no trust me
i'm a human being dude when my client
that's what i'm looking at i'm looking
at myself going god man but then i just
i always have to take a second and be
just hey
this is how you were made you know you
this is this is who you are and
it's
you signed up for this you read it when
you you you said yes so it's it's time
to
to be who you want to be one day you'll
have to explain it to your children
though at some point you realize that
right i think i have a lot of explaining
to do to a lot of people so i don't
think that's ever going to stop great
boy who from this cast would you take on
vacation everybody's so funny and
everyone's so different rel is so
different than yvonne they're both
tremendously gifted stand-ups and
meredith is so so funny and got such a
dynamic personality i actually dig
hanging out with batch uh
king batch is yeah we we had some really
cool conversations offset i'd like to
really see what his life is like it's he
he lives a very interesting presence
having developed comedy uh on social
media platforms and stuff like that and
that's that kind of really interests me
so it's not something i know a lot about
and i want to i want to learn more so i
think maybe him yeah how much of his
life is real and how much of it is
social media right but then again like
here i am a wwe performer when you're a
character on tv with my own name so it's
kind of we kind of run parallels like yo
how much of it is real and how much of
it is you know for the presence of
storytelling so that's i guess that's
why i find it one of the many things
that i find interesting okay you're in
these beautiful locations was there any
partying off the set or did once
everybody wrapped they're like we're
going our separate ways and we're just
gonna go chill or did you kind of kick
it for a while well you know that the
shooting was all partying or a lot of it
was a lot of parties
at the end of the day you you it was
intense partying too so we were all kind
of exhausted at the end of every day and
everybody just kind of went back and and
had a rest we shot in beautiful puerto
rico we had the the run of this amazing
resort and when we weren't in the resort
we were bar hopping legitimately are
hopping so like
after 12 hours of doing that you kind of
need some down time trying to
kind of impress your significant other's
parents is something that we all have
gone through what what is it what has
that been like for you have you had to
do something to impress your significant
other's parents that was a little
strange or hard or surprise you if
you're going out of your way to try to
impress someone i think that's a
slippery slope i think a good piece of
life advice is just be yourself okay and
if people if people aren't happy with
who you are or you don't you're not
going to mesh with everybody then it
becomes brave enough to lean into the
why hey what's what's the problem why
don't we get along it could be
core values it could be
views on um societal issues but that
leads to conversation and conversation
leads to bonding and you know bottling
leads to a relationship how important is
it to keep that
connection with the ring for you to be
able to get back in oh man that's uh
none of this happens without that and i
mean none of my life happens i'm in a
completely
different path to the point of it's not
even hypothetical like that's how long
i've been a member of the wwe family i
can't even say well like in a
hypothetical situation if none of this
existed no i can't there it's my family
and i know i know those days of
physically physically performing are
numbered but i will always be involved
with the wwe in some capacity and it's
that just will never change it's my
family it's my home and i i truly love
it and this
especially this small block of time has
totally taught me that i absolutely love
it what is it about being in the ring
and being a member of the wwe that
translates to you being a superstar in
tv and movie oh dude i've often said
this the wwe is responsible for
uh bettering myself as a professional
bettering myself as a human being it's
taught me humility it's taught me
vulnerability it's it's taught me
empathy it's taught me to listen and not
just blurt out what i want to do
um it's taught me failure
so much time success excitement
intensity like you you name it it's
responsible for so much and one of these
days hopefully in the right form i'll be
able to thank the participants the crew
the audience
for all they've given me in life just in
life in general it's just uh i'm
eternally indebted is there one person
out there you want to get in the ring
the one person right right in front of
me roman reigns for summerslam and the
cool thing is you're gonna you're gonna
find out why on smackdown i think
uh people aren't ready for for what
summerslam means especially to me and i
know uh roman reigns isn't ready to hear
it so i'm really surprised or i'm really
i'm really happy and uh
that i get a chance to to say why this
this match is very special john one of
my favorite things about you is that you
always come rocking the suit is it your
business mentality or what is it and who
makes those suits so i have no style and
a suit is easy
you just try not to clash too much uh
sometimes i you know we all fail so
sometimes i miss but a suit is uniform
and it's easy and like if you look at
who i am even in the wwe sense in wwe
i'm always in my uniform i'm always in
the jorts the ball cap the wristbands so
i i like that sense of i don't have to
worry about this
you know i just let's worry about the
conversation and the details of the
conversation let me put all my efforts
into
uh
worrying about the day and i just
there's something in me and i'm not
taking anything away from people who use
their gift to create style but there's
something in me about somebody dressing
me that isn't for character like
somebody dressing me like hey
individual john cena this is what you
would look good in i just
i like being confident making those
decisions and something that's
streamlined and easy and always looks
to me sharp is a is a suit i love it
last thing your favorite vacation the
place oh man uh honestly i'm
i lean into moments in the holidays
because being a
traveler a traveling performer being on
the road 300 days a year you very rarely
get vacation but we do get
some time around the holidays and
i would always find myself with those i
love family and friends and those those
are the memories that last way beyond a
vista or a landscape
or seeing a building or something like
that it's just time spent with those i
love man
you